this then lovely people is going to be a
freestyle rap that's a wrap made up on
the spot based entirely on suggestions
you guys are real nice what would you
guys like to write about [ __ ]
what did you say a farmer in iowa a
farmer in iowa
thank you very much no rap song ever has
been written about that that's perfect
okay let's go so let's come to this man
who finds gold
what was the first word the brick mason
a brick mason who finds gold
you guys are all very poetic and
eloquent tonight a farmer in iowa the
brick mason who finds gold it feels like
a tarot deck that you're just turning
over
oh the ireland farm oh the gold digging
brick mason
let's come to the middle of the room
well i heard two so if you said how
pluto feels about not being a planet
that's pretty good
and what was the one at the back
a monkey is an animal that's forbidden
by the rules but bolton
great so how pluto feels gold digging uh
brick
guy the that one uh what do you guys
want over here
a sweater vest thank you very much
and what was that overpriced stripper
lovely okay let's just just recap a
farmer in iowa the brick player who
finds
gold a sweater vest an overpriced
stripper and how pluto feels about not
being a planet
usually i only take five but i didn't
get to come around to you guys so i'm
going to take another one bear in mind
this will make me forget
all of them so you might have to be
ready to remind me front row what do you
guys want to wrap up
jeffrey epstein was suggested so many
times the last couple of years don't
take the same position twice what did
you say
i said jeffy yeah there's another one
okay um i should have [ __ ] left that
whole section out right
so to remind you a farmer in iowa a
bricklayer who finds
gold sweater vest overpriced stripper
how pluto feels about not being a planet
maybe jeffrey epstein may be an
underpriced stripper but who knows um
it's a lot
this then lovely people is going to be a
freestyle rap that's a wrap made up on
the spot based entirely on suggestions
it's not going to be repeated it's not
rehearsed it's
all made up and don't worry it's not
anyone near as bad as you're expecting
it to be
if we can uh drop my beat my little band
let's have some fun with this
[Music]
[Applause]
they're magical aren't they it's i'm so
excited for this
where how to do this justice i think
we'll start with you
oh please don't clap please do not clap
you will throw
them off the beat i love it let's do it
the clapping match up with the drum
sound i'd be digging in the soil i'd be
toiling in the ground
seeing in the middle of the states i can
go there i'll show you [ __ ] idaho i'm in
iowa
a little farmer with the four letters
the state no one does it better yeah
this a love letter to my favorite spot
my favorite little tuber i love to cut
you up fry you and then consume you
i'm working hard from early in the
morning everybody else throwing wheat
growing corn but it dawns on me
after dark i'm like no potatoes that's
my favorite starch i'm down on my ears
praying to the lord in the skies
a hole in my potato don't have the eyes
there the little green bits taste really
bitter i'm gonna spend the cash on an
overpriced stripper that i make from my
agriculture
spinning around the pole and you know
that i devote you my whole life i see
you there in the club
i know i got a sit back hands on show
there's no touching
but if she's there afternoon i know that
she takes me to the private room i say
[ __ ] girl you're looking so nice i don't
even mind that you're being overpriced
why because you're in nyc the state tax
it doesn't matter get the notes how i'll
take that she says christy you wanna see
my twin
she sat less attractive not identical in
the womb
still siblings looking great so i take
the money over there she's like mate
hold up
a little bit she's like 20 less still
she's a stripper so i see the breast
undressed i like that
yeah she's not a teen why cause i'm not
like jeffrey epstein
he liked them much younger he had that
hunger a pedophile pedophile well
i can plunk for one of those either way
did he kill himself he was in the cell
hanging up was his mental health stable
or was it the nsa creeping in like sup
jeffrey when he was there was he wearing
the fatigues of the prison or was it
some other clothing that he need was he
wearing something maybe
down dressed not like a stripper but
he's got a down vest mixed with the
sweater
you can see the wool get a bit of yarn
and it's very harmful
i like to wear it when i'm rocking now
everybody observes they're like sweater
vests bro
are you some kind of nerd nah i just
like to protect my torso
i like to take a dig where the mortar
goes between the bricks
for this little bit i pick some take
away all the cement and the gypsum if
you don't know how the mortars proved
i can spit some little lyrics right for
you it's kind of odd as a job carry
bricks with a hood and you hope that one
day you're gonna hit that
g-o-d add an l then it [ __ ] rhymes
getting that gold every single time i
see a little cash
a little treasure trove i take my pick
and i blast through and don't you know
now i'm so rich like a californian in
the gold rush
how many if i count well or push we can
start with mercury
and move to the other one [ __ ] i've
forgotten but venus got it going on
earth mars jupiter and saturn then we go
up to uranus
and neptune but bro how does pluto feel
it's not nice it thought it was a planet
but they said nah
block of ice like a weird little rock
just flowing that's not nice they must
have cried every night when they said
you're just a satellite
pluto says oh no so he does like epstein
committed suicide but he's a planet so
that's it team yeah
[Music]
you